can you name one shared value that binds
Americans together one thing we can
agree on
talking about fundamental basic things
and there really is nothing you want to
answer well we all believe in freedom
but that clearly is not the case or at
the very least we you know that will
raise the question of okay what is
freedom how do we understand that term
so we don't have freedom in common we
don't have anything in common and that
is a serious problem and one we should
be talking about what is it that binds
America together we are people but at
what sense are we eight people and it
would seem like the only thing is just
the borders that we all happen to live
within the same borders but then of
course those borders are being erased so
we don't even have that anymore